-Now, obviously,
you know you're up against
the legacy of the first film
and you have to
figure out funny bits,
and you have to figure out
how to land
this political commentary
in a way
that felt incredibly fresh
But I will say, the part
that really blew me away,
amongst everything else,
the relationship --
The father-daughter relationship
in this film
is really beautiful.
Did you know from the beginnin
that that would have to be
the backbone of this,
or was it something you foun
in the writing?
-Yeah, that was --
I mean, we had a challenge
right.
We're making another "Borat.
And the first "Borat"
went down amazingly well.
We thought nobody in the world
would want to see a movie
about an anti-Semitic journalist
from Central Asia
that was a documentary.
But then we're set with doin
this new one and bring it ou
before the election, making sure
it's, you know, satirical.
Obviously, you've got
all these other challenges
trying to get into
Trump's inner circle.
But, yeah -- But fundamentally
me and the other writers
realized it's gonna be emotion
You've got to actually car
about the relationship
between Borat and his daughter
So we looked at a bunch of
kind of, father-daughter movie
like "Fiddler on the Roof.
Not the Kazakh version,
which is they just throw a Jew
off a building.
But, you know, all these -
"Paper Moon."
All these sort of
arranged-marriage movies.
'Cause you actually have t
want these two characters
to be together.
-So, there's -- I mean,
as thrilling as any scene
in an action movie last year
was you dressing up
in a full Trump costume
and breaking into CPAC.
Can you talk about
what you had to go through
to get into the building?
-Yeah, well -- So, that da
was pretty much like this.
I wake up at 2:00 in the
morning, drive to some motel
There's a full prosthetics team.
They spent five hours
turning me into Donald Trump
And then, yeah, you know -
We obviously have to get through
various layers of Secret Service
then hid in a bathroom
for another four hours.
And then I was concerned that --
I essentially got taken
by the Secret Service
after I did the scene.
I had 15 --
15 kind of different
law-enforcement people
around me.
And I knew that I couldn't
let them know who I was,
because then word would get out.
And if my name got out there
infiltrating CPAC,
the movie would be done.
So, you know,
I had one of the cops --
You know,
there's 15 guys around me.
And there's a guy
with a big badge, and he goes,
"Give me your I.D."
And I said,
"I'm not giving over my I.D.
I don't know
if you're law enforcement.
He was like, "Look at my badge!"
And I go, "Well, I don't kno
if that's a real badge."
And then one of the other guys
says,
"Just give me your I.D."
And I said, "It's in my shoe
Do you want me
to take off my shoe?"
And he's like,
"Oh, yeah, you're right."
Then I carry on
for a few minutes.
And then one of the other
Secret Service guys says,
"Where's his I.D.?"
And he goes,
"Well, it's in his shoe."
You know. And he goes, "So
what?! Get it out of the shoe!
Then the Secret Service
take me into a separate room
And I'd hired a bail lawye
for them --
in case they arrested me.
And I'm in the room,
and they close this door.
And I can hear
my bail lawyer going,
"Let me in. I represent the --
My client is behind the door!"
And I said --
They started questioning me.
And I said,
"I'd seen all the movies."
I go, "I refuse
to answer any questions
until my lawyer is present!"
And I go, "And he's just
outside that door.
I insist he be let in!"
They go,
"we're the Secret Service.
It doesn't work like that.
You can answer the questions."
So they basically decided
not to arrest me.
They said,
"Get off the property."
Then, what they didn't realize
was, about two minutes later
we had two other people also -
One was a Trump impersonator
and one was a stuntman
dressed also in
a prosthetic mask as Trump
So, they say,
"You come back here,
you're going to be arrested.
Two minutes later, these two
guys come into the -- into CPAC,
and they're
immediately arrested.
And they, you know, are
surrounded by Secret Service
One is like,
"Take that mask off your face!
And the guy goes,
"This is my face!"
The trump impersonator
had no idea what's going on.
And then the stuntman --
They go,
"We told you, if you come back
you're going to be arrested!
After an hour with
a prosthetics makeup artist,
they removed the mask
and realized it wasn't me.
So it was a challenge.
-All right.
I mean, again,
I know you've been through
some of these
white-knuckle moments.
Are you a little terrified
when you're in the room
with Secret Service like that?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Yes. I mean, you don't --
You don't think anything violent
is going to happen to you,
although there was --
There was one point when we were
preparing the Giuliani scene
with somebody who had
Secret Service protection,
and I had to get trained
on what to do
when the person's got
Secret Service protection.
I won't say who it is.
Shout, "Help, help."
So, you know,
I was trained on what you do
Essentially, the first thing
that a secret Service
person does,
is they jump on you in the room.
So the advice was
lie on the floor
'cause they're gonna
jump on you.
That's, you know --
They're big guys.
And they're trying to,
obviously, you know --
to stop whoever is getting
you know, shot.
So they don't know.
That's the first protocol.
And so I -- We went through th
kind of training on what to do
In the end, we didn't --
didn't go ahead
with that person,
and we ended up with Giuliani.
-Well, I can only say thank yo
for continuing
to take these risks.
And congratulations
on both films.
They were both wonderful.
And it was really great
talking to you.
-Thank you, Seth. Thank you.
Thank you for having
my least-funny character
on your show.
-We're glad --
We're glad to finally --
He should get out more.
"Borat Subsequent Moviefilm"
is streaming
on Amazon Prime Video.
And "The Trial of the Chicago 7"
is streaming on Netflix.
We'll be right back.